my knee your family my welcome
God Abba messing up dangers these days
random boo traffic there we go alright
so welcome back to condom come you guys
doing in there having a parade without
me ah
are there shooting cops
it's not cool all right
crowbar time airs doesn't work out
whatever hello we get papers boot it
boot everything that we don't like I
don't like your face booted okay I think
where you take that later maybe I don't
do you why not we need to save Rosa you
know the ugly [ __ ] I mean they're
beautiful on the inside chick that needs
a mister shower DJ Jodi yeah damn you're
looking fine sir mr. Shane fancy I can't
talk today oh yeah yeah yeah yeah first
vlog Portia's up how did you becomes our
red Crowley I do not pity
maybe that's the murdering out of the
people huh that wasn't me
there's someone else oh we're back here
I get i hate when it's saved coin
because you know something sneak mode
activate hey guys hey guys
buh buh hey don't tell me what the [ __ ]
oh hey what there we go kind of run away
from me give this some machine whoa it's
awesome let's see where we're going
are you doing that there's a computer
keyring in rare books law library rare
books
all right this way can open this I did
you claire-bear
hello mr. chair again you can tell it
for I like that I wish I could tell
apart beautiful painting hi mines look
at that horse that horses it's Jane
Austen that a horse it's pretty badass
oh [ __ ] and he's like must [ __ ] this
later but first pet this horse it's all
beautiful all right I guess man whoa
that was [ __ ] loud I don't trust
Ayers
wow what a half
Oh mister shout tell you what spirit
what oh yeah I'm gonna get you for this
that's right what is that lady doing huh
I'm pretty tired no headache ladies hey
I'm watching paintings there what's up
[ __ ] I'm so screwed come on man calm
down hey don't get up
vote [ __ ] you man
slapping the voltage and bracket
seriously of course it doesn't have any
[ __ ] ammo any quick thing all right
rare books department this way I wish I
had some health bags alright
Oh gotta find em again yeah all right
show me Rosa are you doing that girl
whoa whoa Hermione
thank you I think we need this sorry
sorry Crowley it's led she wants to play
well maybe you don't need it Rosa come
on man girl whatever you are uh there's
a ladder here maybe use this you
sledgehammer on the ladder
doesn't work come on it showed one
second that it is Wow
that's solid everything oh here we go
on the lock okay I get it yeah whoa
creepy man climb ladder why I do not
know climbing ladder like a baby Romani
be careful
do you doing lady try to break down this
[ __ ]
jump down I feel like I'm gonna die
whoa whoa whoa wow we're good
now you ain't got off you bastard come
any closer and I'll rip your head off
hey that's not 90 Thomas oh oh he must
have clobbered me in the back of the
head before taking off are you okay
there thank you how do we things
standing over you really look well
you're chasing shot is it tried to kill
me I bit him good though right on the
hand
are you okay Rosa did you get any of the
blood sampled I saw some hit the floor
yes I mean yeah and transferred back to
the lab of car accident I'm gonna
excellent I mean I'm an expert
all right pay attention through this
computer I do a remote analysis I'm
gonna find health packs
I can move yeah this kind of way to play
from the sample matches DNA taking the
metro station hideout this is the guy
this is our serial killer ex killed the
policeman why would you do that all of
the other guys on your case list what
did he want with you
pardon I don't know what we knew about
the torturer you made me look it up on
the net he knows the whole mo now the
abduction torture suicide ding Thomas
the torture is on your case list and
he's the only one whose trail hasn't
gone cold since we ran into
serial killer X mm-hmm X wants to
torture to die he's hunting him down
this all makes so much sense in the case
of the torturer serial killer that the
entire gym teacher from the city's
juvenile rehabilitation program has
informed police of contact I can't take
authority zarnow asking the public to
inform police if they know of Carl
Anderson swear a belt
I no longer be located Department
spokespersons have refused comment on
this latest development
okay you're not even looking lady Carl
Anderson to Hatton gym teacher tells the
cops on you and now the teacher can't be
found okay Rosa we have to find the
school where this teacher worked god
damn it I hate schools and City district
records are in the best night to and
it's creepy as hell
follow me hopefully this key will get us
where we need to go sorry that you had
to sit down you're mr. chair
it's okay I smell I know I can smell her
but from here all right
step aside lady I'll open this what the
hell did you just do with that door
she's seriously an Android or a wizard I
don't trust him one second boot him her
whoa goes right through sorry mr. Schine
me today damn
can we smash these whoa we can it did
nothing all right have it book return
booted don't like book returns hey Russ
I did you see this horse is there again
it's so badass Shane look at you you're
so magnificent oh there's the guy that
it is all right I guess all right I
don't know how you have all the keys but
I am not sure if I care are you just
gonna stand there fine better Savior
actually hammington reading whoa it
looks like a puzzle area whoa
wow what the hell are you come crawling
around up there Rosa can you kill them
for me I don't know about this
alright alright we're good
again it looks like this is where the
library suffers [ __ ] me damn it
look what hey Zack there should be a
stairwell that leads down to the
microfiche I need a [ __ ] health pack
hey Rosa don't scare me
alright I got it
yeah all right so you first told me that
if you see like a I am stuff you find
stuff so thank you for the trip whoa
come on man
don't [ __ ] with me rats big as rats man
Rosa don't creep up on me right now I
mean I had enough of your [ __ ] girl all
right
whoa this place burned damn Wow amazing
Rosa I'm not okay I felt like five
floors busted my Milosz light though
[ __ ] me ahh
Thank You Rosa you're so funny it's
anything but oh I hate her now ah [ __ ]
me I have to go in here I come oh come
on
no way shh shh what I don't want to [ __ ]
man says good
George what the hell roast are you
little [ __ ] baka what was it's me snap
out of it
[ __ ] you man yeah I don't trust you
about a second I son make your way
around to the doors on the other side I
thank God I'll let you in there
mr. Shack too long no it's not the time
without my flashlight nervous come on
don't be a pezzi can I go please can I
go believes draws that voltage come on
why not
White has no way through this gate
you'll have to go around yes lady but
there's no way through this way around -
the doors on the other side I'll let you
in there come on sheriff thank you sorry
oh [ __ ] you come on I don't have Rosa
[ __ ] smack me up she got him smack my
[ __ ] shot hey Nick a chihuahua doesn't
work doesn't work doesn't work all the
single ladies
oh dude through books and teleportation
these guys are not playing that's what
you get come on smack it
whoa I kill your friend god damn this
game sometimes what the [ __ ]
I'll have to ever like I've enjoyed the
sky Komarov today and I'll see you next
episode right now make this sandwich
doesn't have turkey an edge freakin get
it right side of a batch of ice ah this
is Robin but I don't get my target